[Music]
first came the grasses they came in six
then smaller shrubs with them the
insects returned then the tree and with
the trees the monkeys and elephants here
at sky sanctuary we have over 300 acres
of forest that we have replanted and
brought back to life my full name is
Pamela Gayle Malhotra and I am
co-founder with my husband of size
sanctuary trust it had always been our
dream to have a private forest sanctuary
for wildlife where they would be
protected when we first came here most
of the lands that were sold to us were
abandoned land abandoned rice field
coffin and Hardiman fields as well a lot
of deforestation had taken place and
that took a lot a lot of care and energy
and time and years to bring it back to
really done really really well people
thought we were quite crazy but that's
okay a lot of people have thought people
there's done some amazing things are
crazy here in the sanctuary
it is a biodiversity hotspot I remember
walking through the forest you wouldn't
hear anything but the sound of your own
feet now the place is alive the sounds
one of our main sound makers are the
cicadas they have a tremendous decibel
range okay here they start again we keep
striving to do more and more but the
initial goal has been more than achieved
my hopes for the next ten years for this
forest is that it will continue to be
protected and expanded we both feel a
tremendous amount of joy when we walk
through the sanctuary I've never felt
this kind of joy in anything else that
I've done in my life
[Music]